hey guys how's it going so I wanted to
do this little unboxing video today
because i pre-ordered this amiibo stand
a long time ago because I couldn't
really find any amiibo stands that were
awesome and clearly judging by this one
it looks pretty awesome the only problem
is you're not gonna really be able to
display very many on it so let's uh no I
don't have any scissors
oh it's officially licensed custom
molded displays up to size right here
just lays up to six and move of figures
over 15 inches tall at 18 inches wide
okay this is really big this is a lot
bigger than I thought it looked a little
smaller on the Internet
that usually tends to happen what I
don't like is to come off like what the
heck if you guys can see there's it's
not a fully molded brick each piece
looks like it's been stuck together and
it kind of doesn't look that good I feel
like it could have been a lot better
this is cool okay
Charlie where do we stick it where do I
put these causes how do you work this
thing what do we do here okay
put you here I do like that they have a
little cutout holes here so you can just
put the amiibo right in and it'll sit
nicely on top which is pretty cool it's
pretty cool
did you do it Maddie's looking at me
like you're crazy so let's pop some
amiibo on here how's our junior real
chunky dr. Mario oh these fit very very
nice this looks good that's my official
review I've got some complaints but
they're very minimal the fact that these
are not all fully molded together there
are two separate pieces it upsets me a
little bit but you know what I'm gonna
let it slide I'm gonna let it slide give
you guys a close-up look at this thing
yeah you look fantastic
so that's this pretty neat little amiibo
stand just let me don't you guys think
of it I think it's pretty cool I'm into
it I love me Bo so much and I will have
to do an amiibo collection video for you
guys I'm still missing a few so I've got
an update that I think this is gonna
hopefully fit on my shelf I'm not really
sure if it's going to but we'll find out
see you guys later
thanks for watching